if you're having tea with the giant
Hello Kitty doll then you're almost
certainly in Japan this is a place that
specializes in obsessing over things and
taking every want and need to their
unnatural extreme if you desire a
refreshing drink there's a vending
machine that will evaluate your face and
pick the perfect beverage or perhaps you
prefer to imbibe while in the company of
an ornamental owl whoa-ohh or two down a
latte with the three-dimensional robot
as garnish
ah that's good robot good Japanese of
course also fetishize technology like no
other culture Japan's once glorious tech
shine may have dulled with the decline
of Sony and other empires but without
question there's a new tech movement on
the rise I'm traveling from Tokyo to
Osaka and Kyoto to meet the Japanese
inventors bringing this new culture to
life where we go along the way I'll meet
an eccentric figure who wants to live to
a hundred forty-four hang with some
robots that could kick my ass and lose
myself in this trippy Wonderland all in
this episode of hello world Silicon
Valley may be home to some of the
biggest tech giants in the world but
it's being challenged like never before
crazy tech geniuses have popped up all
over the planet making things that will
blow your mind my name is Ashley Vance
I'm an author and journalist and I'm on
a quest to find the most innovative tech
creations and meet the beautiful freaks
behind them
where else would I begin my journey but
in Tokyo
millions of people make their way around
the city in an orderly fashion doing
their best not to bother anyone the
hustle of modern life dominates the city
but it's at night the Tokyo really comes
to life open a sliding door and an
explosion of people and food await
inside or you might head here to the
robot restaurant
as touristy and insane as all of this is
it actually gets to the heart of Japan's
relationship with robots
the machines here come with stories and
personality they're good they're bad and
sometimes they eat people
but far away from the fire-breathing
dinosaurs and werewolf guitarists
researchers at a Tokyo Museum have set
up a workshop where they're looking to
prove that robots can be imbued with
life eat your red pill and try to keep
up professor Takashi Ikegami has helped
create this thing which looks like it
comes straight from ex machina central
casting through a series of sensors and
artificial intelligence software this
android looks out into the world and
reacts to what it sees the Android is an
effective olve it based on what it's AI
software seems to like basically two
different mechanisms one is autonomous
or rhythm generators okay it's coupled
with each other
also there is artificial neural networks
spontaneously firing and sending signals
to each other someone approaches the
Android the sensors detect the movement
and then the software kicks in to
determine how the robot will move in
response
but for the moment it has a movement
style that could be described as that
really drunk guy at the party okay so in
each one of these sensor boxes right
here yes there's two cameras yep and
this is measuring measuring the distance
so when I come closer or further away
from the machine then both what it has
to do something it has to do react to
them yeah you guys will add more and
more sensors yeah we can put like a
temperature sensors sound sensors many
other fences armed with more sensors the
robot can make more judgments about its
environment and more nuanced reactions
over time the movements and gurgles
change
the thinking is that the robot will
eventually form its own personality and
possibly even language what's the deal
with the noise is that hungry this sound
is it designed by my student the
behavior is modifying those sounds the
sound is changing all the time it's more
like in a primitive language that's I
think the interesting part of it like
our babies we don't have to tell
everything to the baby but baby can
learn unconsciously by interacting with
people just like with the environment
right once we have a bunch of lifelike
systems around us
maybe our concept of what is life would
be very much different and then if we
want to coexist with robots they will
maybe have to learn different languages
different way of thinking
so that doesn't freak you out you think
that's a go justice I think it's much
more ideal to me ok with this you know
very violent world right now well thank
you for letting me see your Android
thank you thank you
oh she said something I think he said he
likes you
one of Takashi's robot building
colleagues works in osaka making some of
the most lifelike androids ever built so
I hopped on a bullet train to witness
the demise of mankind firsthand
even on a tame Tuesday night
Osaka lives up to its reputation as one
of the most vibrant food capitals in all
the world
vendors making all manner of delicacies
fill the streets in between high-rises
but the creation our master resides in a
more sedate part of town meet Erica
she's the creation of Hiroshi Ishiguro a
professor at Osaka University's
intelligent robotics laboratory mr. Goro
has become famous for his pursuit of a
lifelike Android I think this is the
most beautiful face in the world she's
killed in tjuta absolutely our challenge
is to install the intention desire to
this robot so without the intention
there's Aria in other Android it cannot
be emotional and under cannot understand
other people whose intention desires
right what kind of desires to zarok am
she want to be well recognized because
she's a kind of an exhibitionist with
this laboratory her job is to be a
receptionist that's the receptionist or
secretary or something like that do you
mind walking me through things she can
hear
you see you know this communities I'll
call you myself
no let's go Massimo's man esteemeth a
massacre honeycomb-like iam is kinda yo
what happened she got angry she got
angry well I say no I say that much much
much much is a kind of joke alright so
you always say mush mush if you're on
the phone
right right right so it was rude that
it's an in-person yeah Erica listens
through an array of microphones hidden
in the flowerpot no and relies on
electronics and sensors for her movement
an AI software for her responses Hiroshi
thinks Erica lives up to the term Suns
icon which means she admits something
akin to a human presence
how do you think and she is like a human
or just a wax model or so I get to see
these robots all over the place
to me it's one of the most lifelike ever
machine and Hiroshi has an interesting
proposition for me that would test how
close to human I think Erica really is
if you wanna be Ruben that was all right
if I was gonna kiss this robot yes I
would be the song's icon okay have you
ever kissed Erica no this is the Japan
right though we are not in a United
States riser Japanese never do that
my guess is that we're gonna have a huge
bar I kiss for the robots we have a huge
variety for the car right very cheap
causing economy car right button we also
have a Ferraris and in a Porsche and
this is a kind of a Ferrari and up next
I head to Kyoto for a lesson in robotics
history and to hang out with some other
less terrifying robots that you might
actually let near your children
if you want to learn about robot culture
Kyoto is as good of a place to start as
any
for hundreds of years it has been the
showcase city for Japan's most famous
traditions from geishas spectacular
temples over in the University District
you can also find some of Japan's best
technological minds I've come to
Doshisha University to dive deep into
Japan's love affair with robots with the
professor and one of Japan's most active
robot hobbyists a Tunisian Engram I know
he only hired an embosser hyah
till you gain about a hockey puck Sean
got a guillotine oh God he don't talk
chewy not eat it Wow yeah gears got good
news Takashi Hori mochi embodies a
Japanese concept known as a taco it
refers to a person who obsesses over
something be it hello kitty sushi for
robots for Takashi robotics is more than
a hobby it's his passion most of his
free time goes into assembling these
things by hand out of 3d printed body
parts and electronics do you work on
these almost every day yes about two
hours for mostly Nostromo eat soup is
very Tomo can I eat it that's cool yeah
each one takes months to build including
the software for the choreographed lose
but it's not all for show these robots
must fight to earn their keep akira
would i hit other robots uh yeah that
good yeah
one of Takashi's robots recently took
first place in a competition making him
king of the otaku
and when you're the king there are
people that want to study you one of
Japan's foremost researchers into the
relationship between man and BOTS is
Hiro Fumi kutsuna an anthropologist here
at doe sheesha University I was looking
for you know that the passionate people
who work on robots I joined a group and
started to create my own robots and
YouTube met at the end in the advance
Hiro felt compelled to ask that Seinfeld
II in question what's the deal with
Japan and all those robots it's related
to Japan's sort of national quest to
establish its own identity and after the
World War two
so after the sort of a devastation of
the whole land Japan started to rebuild
the nation through promoting the
peaceful use of science and technology
in that process I think many anime
creators and manga creators started to
ponder the kind of ideal relationship
between the Japanese and technology for
South Dakota saga now some who who is a
creative elastro boy hero is not alone
and pointing to the significance of
astro boy the manga series started in
the 1950s and has a mad scientist-type
building an Android to replace his dead
son the saga goes on to explore what
life would be like if humans and robots
coexist and it's that very same idea
that one local tech giant has invested
millions of dollars to pursue Hitachi
produces a shocking amount of stuff from
brain scanners right on up to nuclear
reactors this being Japan it's also in
the robot game I've gone to one of the
company's vaunted research labs to see
its latest take on the robot that people
desire most an autonomous helper Hitachi
calls this creature EMU
I am you
okay Amy was developed as a sort of
friendly robot concierge equipped with
AI for navigation and speech recognition
he might provide directions at an
airport or do some low-level security
work or he might be kicked over by a
cynical reporter looking for a good time
that's pretty cool
that resemblance between EMU and my pal
Hello Kitty is on purpose
EMU's designer hace baba wanted the
robot to have the same harmless non
creepy feel is it meant to look like a
child yes because everyone liked it
nevertheless shut up the eyes cleared up
there's an adorable quality to these
robots and they may be helpful one day
for the moment though rolling around
looking cute is about the extent of what
they can do and they're super expensive
to make you have a price that you're
aiming to get to we've applied to you
know cheap a sound uh car be cheaper
than a car huh okay what's that EMU you
want to make up for your failings by
showing me an autonomous vehicle okay
thanks Evie you here's my rad this sweet
hog with the flip top door is called
rope it's
the way we go it's sort of like a
self-driving car but is meant to travel
down sidewalks instead of on the road
and this is the vehicles inventor Ryo ki
kitchen OC coupe ahead sister Kanta
Oh Co Ducati galvanized o2n typically do
any pseudo textio neato akuto - stigmas
to Cebu chika Soto scallopini demo
Coolio Sundance universe newbie - there
you my demo to get it most la Japan's
aging population has forced the country
to try and invent new ways to help
seniors make their way around cities the
idea here is that someone can summon the
car to their house and then go for a
leisurely drive to the store the open
windows and slow speed of rope it's
means that the driver can even have a
chat with a friend for perhaps an enemy
walking nearby
it's a beautiful utopian future the
tachi is imagining for us all full of
smart compassionate robots attending to
our every need but suffice it to say
that future very much remains the future
the wall the wall where we doing helping
you up next I returned to Tokyo for a
few surprises that thankfully have
nothing to do with robotics at all glad
I didn't take acid before we carry one
in Tokyo
it's a geek rite of passage to visit
Akihabara this district in the heart of
the city has long been the place that
locals and tourists go to to buy
electronics and mash buttons
Oh anything your nerdy nerdy heart
desires can be found in Akihabara be it
esoteric robot parts the cafe staffed
entirely by maids or a real-life version
of Pokemon go only way way more
frustrating
come on my kids
come on
this is just sorry kids daddy couldn't
catch them all not far away in the
suburb of citta Gaia there's another
temple to Japan's inventive ways it's
the home / laboratory of dr. Nakamatsu
know you're famous when you've got your
own Street Avenue and square right
outside your house dr. Nakamatsu zacchi
--vs the lab status through his numerous
inventions walking into his house is
like stepping into a QVC graveyard of
forgotten and obscure gadgets
some of his inventions are legit many
years ago he patented the floppy disk
and a popular suction device used
throughout homes in Japan dr. Nakamatsu
you for having us here
Oh welcome they're coming to Japan and
the welcome to dr. Nakamatsu house that
was reading that you invented the floppy
disk the CD the fax machine the drone
why do you think you don't get credit
for all of these inventions yeah because
I'm always looking new things I'm
working Saturday Sunday holiday yeah I
haven't no holiday in addition to being
a pro at dodging questions the good
doctors biggest claim to fame as having
more patents than anyone else
Thomas Sr made 1093 and he did that 84
am now 88 my number is 3500 and this is
still increasing because I'm still
living yeah not incredible but not all
of dr. Nakamatsu inventions are addison
esque
this is a weapon inside and when you
have somebody coming at this this is dr.
Nakamatsu otter
despite a change pata technologies this
pata can control board direction and
distance
the doctor has even developed an
over-the-counter solution for one of
Japan's biggest economic problems in
Japan the population is decreasing and
decreasing this is subject
but the forebrain makes miserable 6 and
this object no needle for free just the
spray away from dr. Nakamatsu his
amazing loved use Japan's creative
thinking has stalled in recent years to
find out why I joined my friend noriaki
Okubo for a chat about Japan's tech
scene over noodles Aki is a
well-connected tech guru venture
capitalist and champion noodle slurper
know worked on my slurp technique after
a week in Japan I had so many questions
for him how would you compare the
Japanese VC scene to say Silicon Valley
traditional VCS are really bad because
they don't want to take risk there
there's a lot of new VCS
that are doing pretty well new Internet
companies and you know they can take
risk but not the traditional you know
salaryman type VC yeah manake says
salaryman he's talking about that image
we have of the conservative hard-working
Japanese businessman this culture
rewards conformity and safe business
decisions according to Aki it's a key
factor in the fall of Japan's tech
dominance in favor of the disruptive
mentality of Silicon Valley
the decisions that come up from that
kind of process is always going to be
you know let's just do something that's
okay and nothing cool yeah what's that
company that does the robotic vacuum
cleaners Oh Roomba or remote yeah yeah
so Panasonic or Sony could have made
that easily but then in their meetings
somebody would say okay so what if this
falls from the stairway and there's a
baby and it hits the Beave and kills it
let's not do this it's too risky is
there a big college to change the way
you're thinking I mean I think there is
but it's just still very the minority
yeah well hockey's take on technology
here holds true in the big picture there
are plenty of people and companies that
see themselves as rebels trying to buck
the system and no one exemplifies this
better than Toshi Yukio Naoko and his
company team lab for an OCO inspiration
struck when he was just eight years old
he's in Uganda green in my second year
of junior high I usually tell people
that an electric wave struck I'm not
sure what it actually was or even how to
describe this but a strong sense of duty
that I needed to do something that had
meaning in society suddenly came over me
if that red pill is still circulating
through your system then this will feel
perfect let's see if we can go find a
fish it's one of team labs world-famous
techno art experiences they use this
projection mapping technology to track
the fish when they hit somebody's body I
supposed to turn into a flower
alright we're supposed to move on
you tell em all
how long does it take to do one of these
projects not forever
no we take one idea and create
reconsider then repeat the process for
example the exhibit you saw crystal
universe is that we've been working on
for five years the pool one we've been
working on for two to three years team
lab has around 400 employees thinking up
new ever weirder things and working in
their makeshift laboratories what's this
one
very not got good spin again you're
making clothes right I think it's for a
show it's for a dancer no he's making
clothes for a mascot
Oh duh here we're experimenting with a
device that allows you to manipulate
waves in the water you're gonna make
patterns in the water and control the
pattern yeah that's cool Kanako is known
throughout Japan as a flamboyant
character for him you either create
something new or you grow old and stay
quiet la you know is that I love
Japanese society has age too much it is
a society of old people it's
conservative and it can't seek value in
new things so you're trying to change
that no no no no no no I want to be with
people who want to take a step into the
new world
people who are creative you want to
change the world these people I hope to
inspire and to have an influence on or
by having them experience our art I want
to shake their values out of things so
rather than taking on people who don't
want change I work to inspire people who
want to change
it's an OCO and the people wired like
him
the two seem to be Japan's best hope for
a major technology resurgence the
well-funded robotics labs and corporate
giants do amazing research but they've
struggled to keep pace with places like
Silicon Valley and China when it comes
to making products that actually reach
consumers Japan remains trapped between
two worlds the old and the new it's a
country that has turned the future into
a religion but that must still deal with
an aging population and rigid customs
the way forward for Japan its chance to
really make a mark will almost certainly
come from its robots EMU for one is
already getting ready to be a guide and
chauffeur at the 2020 Olympics for now I
say goodnight to Japan may all our
dreams be filled with Hello Kitty up
next on hello world I head to Russia
to fly drones in Siberia hang with a
techno oligarch wow this is really cool
and get beaten with a birch branch
you